you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up 5o game French
defense winnow are all ready let's see
what we get here okay and now what we've
been here before I believe now let's put
the knight on e7 what other options does
he have and that movement I could go in
for castles
but yeah we're going down a lot of
theory right now okay I'm going to play
Queen here I'm going to be gamba ting
upon and how about we start with night
here Queen takes g7 rook g8 I'm going to
be going clean side and maybe we could
learn something from this I constantly
not not grabbing on g7 why not okay
maybe I will Castle kingside
what are my other options
no severely weakened my dark squares I
don't want a castle so I'm still I still
have it in my mind I want to go
queenside serious concession gave up my
better bishop and okay I don't want to
see h5 so I'm going to go h5 myself
weakening some more squares I see I
realize but I think that's ok but we
first capture Queen here clean here
straight away let's go clean here
straight away
yeah my nights are collect connected
Queen f6 I just duck that move is pretty
aggressive
what's wrong with maybe snipping the c2
pond
let's take care first why are they
giving me the c2 pond don't really
understand that because I could threaten
a queen exchange as well soon maybe
multiple spots from my queen
okay that live I didn't really consider
suppose I take here let's take stuff
maybe more stuff going hunting now I'm
officially a pawn grabber in this game
can I get away with another pone let's
find out I think I can offering a queen
exchange and I'm ready to pick up a
third I don't see any great Bishop
discoveries after I go here clean takes
Knight takes I love to Fonz ready lay on
the fork Bishop g2 seems natural you got
this other guy wrong feel this is just
excellent here Knight to e2 would be a
help mate
in multiple ways ah let's just about
move forward threaten another pawn
although this time around I don't know
if I want to capture this guy hmm
I'm going to need to develop probably
grab this pond at a later stage and
it'll be fine
alright so there's a saying no soup for
me
no castling for me okay that's a bit of
an irritating mode okay yeah that's a
bit of a bug alright let's start with
this they may try to just push on with
this guy how do I complete development
it's actually pretty tricky
okay I'm up to pawns but it doesn't feel
like it alrighty
yeah this bishop is enormous okay feel
like I'm close to getting back rank made
it as well yikes
okay I feel that that helped me a little
bit and put my knight here they could
try to take him out but I wouldn't be
too upset with giving up upon just to
give my King some breathing space that's
maybe what they're going for let's start
with this also Bishop h5 straight away I
could take that pawn
I'm willing to give up the exchange if I
could maybe let's see let's start with
this I think the cheque simply improves
I was going to say I'm willing to give
up the exchange if I could eliminate
this pond like if the bishop locks in
here I could try and track oh no no no I
would have been a bad form of a pretty
move I got a sack my rook for the bishop
and this pond here be fine with that I
may have may happen because this rook
has to be freed up at some point I have
this check I don't know really what
that's doing though can I challenge this
bishop with my knight maybe I could try
for something like that let's go here or
even this night night East 7a push how
about a knight on f5 it's hard to say
also another thing if he isn't around
yeah this is what I was talking about so
now I could take in multiple ways but
yeah well I can't take the rook that's
one is defended and he's ready to
promote so I will be getting this pawn
I'll have a 3rd pawn and the minor piece
no way to defend a5 and so these guys
should get rolling soon I have perfect
coordination and right now he's a bad
Bishop but once these guys get rolling
it should be a big problem for t-money
let's see this f-pawn is going to try to
limit me yeah I guess we're gonna have
to go here
stop stroke h8 step my king up
I don't want to move my night so soon I
don't want to give this rook activity my
back crank let's just go here AF King to
f6 and let's go here okay hmm
I didn't want to have to run it like
this but
to push this is a very valuable pawn but
I think my king in the center could
start to threaten some stuff these two
advances I would like to have the center
pawn around all right let's start with
this it opens it opens up my bishop and
maybe I can move my knight Wits checked
the King's not careful you're
threatening to win upon and I'm going to
go here I'm willing to give a pawn up I
want to keep a rook on this is very
important yes
rook activity could threaten the
exchange or in exchange of rooks I have
this check let's go here I'm defending
the pawn watch my bishop has that this
is the threat if this guy's unprotected
what's this clock situation situation 38
let's just play here we're going to
connect drug store not connecting rooks
and because of that I'm running the rook
and time should not be an issue now
everything is defended and yeah let's
just go pawn hunting some more push
through very soon no steel matrix
involves here I'm not getting skewered
I guess we'll run with this guy they're
trying to burn my time at this point but
I am continually making improvements the
pawn has gone far enough
that was really bad what I did he worked
so hard and now he's now he's dead let's
try see if they're about this let's make
it really simple there I calculated that
okay my pawn be caught no he's not
inside the box yeah I really have to
review this opening stage cuz I know
they could have a captured on g7 so
we'll have a look at that stuff see what
more we could take away from this game
that's going to do it
okay yeah just some quick thoughts
before I have a look at it with the
engine
I know Knight to e7 is a move I've seen
also just a quick queen a5 and then this
with the idea to completely shut down
the Queen side stop this wasn't one of
the ideas with a quick queen a5 into a 4
is to limit the light or excluding the
dark square bishop so that a for Bishop
a3 is no longer an option so you take
that out of the equation and you could
go further
Queeny Queeny 5 Queen a4 and go further
with c4 locking things down in it
becomes a pretty big strategic battle
night night versus Bishop position that
was my better bishop that I gave up for
the night but I'm getting something in
return and that is a shattered Queen
side structure for white so I went with
Knight to e7 queen g4 this is kind of uh
and I'm very new to me alright I should
say I don't have much experience with
this but some reason I think even king -
king - f8 is a move I think I could
Castle as well it's important that I
have this move or even excuse me I have
Knight to f5 as well in reply to Bishop
h6 tax the bishop
defends off the mate but uh you know I
don't know how it played out in the game
I just want a bunch of pawns but I could
have done a better job I didn't want to
have to get it to a point or I would
have preferred to not let it get to a
point where I would have to invest back
the exchange like I did I think they
helped me out a little bit you know they
moved their Bishop right into g7 I was
more than happy to give that back this
pawn was worth more than upon being
passed on h6 so it probably could have
made me struggle a bit more keeping the
Bishop on f6 because he was a really
nice into my position I wasn't able to
castle so easily but you know just kind
of went on a pawn hunting tear in the
opening here and was able to give the
exchange later
let's just dive right in with the engine
and see what more we could take away
from this one all righty this is exactly
where I want to be so French defense win
or variation advance to be a bit more
exact and yeah that's the idea
97 okay
24
to go straight in forecastles is this
really so bad playing Queen to a5 now I
guess it's another move so I was
pointing out King Fe but you could just
get away with castles many different
moves here as you're seeing and it's
still hovering right around equal ish so
you could go in for this Bishop h6 is
probably just not good because of Knight
to f5 counter punch initially I thought
simply Knight to g6 but why not defend
and throw a jab right back at like
hitting the bishop and he has to go
elsewhere so you could Castle here but
some some care certainly has to be you
know you have to take some care of this
position because I'm lacking some space
on the Kings side this guy right here on
e5 often acts as a catalyst for an
attack so you know robbing this f6
Square from my knight so I had in my
mind still that I wanted to maybe one
day Castle queenside didn't happen in
this game but from here where there are
some issues c4 is maybe a possibility
yeah they could go straight in for this
that's what I thought they would do so
what did I exactly have it's actually
two pawns but it isn't completely clear
it's probably a position where you have
to give it some time for the computer to
crunch the numbers I will be going Queen
side here I have a lead in development
and I kind of had it in my mind that I
would do something like this and put
some pressure on d4 I don't know how
good it is so it's still around upon
advantage for white but their center is
coming under some pressure here and
their queen isn't quite tied in with any
other piece at least at the moment it's
an inch it makes for a very interesting
game that's for sure
go in that direction didn't grab on g7
so this allowed me to save the pond for
one which makes my positional sense of
became you know I kind of cringe when I
make a move like that because I know
what I'm potentially signing up for you
don't have a dark square bishop and
you're making a pond you're moving one
of your pawns off of the dark square
yeah you're you're subjected to some
serious weaknesses so these pop right
out at me and sure enough we got to see
that in action
my opponent made use of that f6 square
trying to pry things open now h5
hovering around equal ish and see yeah I
think it's close to just downhill from
here after my opponent's next move
well they did I just went on with g4 so
they didn't do anything about me picking
up the C pawn yeah and this just isn't a
good idea so g4 is no good they had to
go with suggesting a capture on c5 and
that's going to get pretty pretty weird
D take C Knight to f5 Queen take C -
maybe Knight takes here one day not just
yet so Queen f6 with a double attack
some interesting possibilities with that
line after g4 however is it always
better for black from here on out again
I still think when I was up a couple
ponds when I had that material advantage
I thought that I could have converted it
better so let's let's see how I could
have maybe made things a bit more smooth
I capture first on d4 that's fine and
then Queen to be - with the double
back it likes it's minus three
and once the cleans are off we want to
go with Knight takes d4 but I'm a fan of
the Queen trade especially when up
material here just made a lot of sense
to do that and it's still - - but I felt
like my opponent fought back when this
bishop was on f6 so I think we're going
to be seeing a change in the evaluation
you know here's another thing if this
was so much of an issue maybe I should
have returned here with this Knight
instead of moving forward
just so that these guys stay connected
and I could play Bishop d7 in an Castle
and then that way the bishop is in
controlling d8
I didn't anticipate that maybe another
idea though
okay I just had in my mind and move
forward h5
things started to get a little bit
tricky I did not want to take because
I'm inviting a knight in to f6 and so if
I thought a bishop was really good on f6
and Knight is even better even combined
I imagine a knight on f6 combined with a
bishop on g5 my King is going to have to
run he's gonna have to bolt to the Queen
side so that's why I held my ground I
don't think I've voiced that in the game
that's why I held my ground on capturing
I didn't want to improve the quality of
that Knight so Bishop d7 and then they
cut me out from castling and what more
rook c8
and I went Knight to f5 and was it equal
at some point
it's not so clear just giving about upon
advantage but it's tricky to take
towards the southerner otherwise I'm
dropping d5 I activate
I would be activating two pieces not
just dropping upon I took like that so
Bishop f6 rook h7 I think I have to go
there because going here I'm running it
to this and I don't see how I control h8
oh right here it even wants to castle oh
I didn't even consider castles huh I get
castle and had my king as the block
cater and put my rook on g8 I didn't
even consider that
huh
I totally drew a blank on counseling
here that's kind of cool
defend the rook by castling there and
then have the King as the blockade er
interesting that didn't even come to it
didn't even come to mind this is still a
fine move but yeah I should have
considered castles would have made the
coordination from my side a bit easier
King on h7 then I can put my rooks on g8
hmm okay so they pushed
and if they're an opportunity for white
let's see Bishop f3 let's go look to see
896 yeah I'm just kind of eyeing up the
evaluation seeing if there's any great
shifts Bishop b5 check I thought I would
just be improving the King if I did that
and I guess I I guess I could have just
done that yes I improve it but I get on
with being able to get my King to an
active post I probably would have
followed up like this I could be in some
trouble though sacrificing this square
something I'd have to look out for but
it I felt fine which is going to see six
even though it was strictly defensive
let's say and vacating d7 for my King
everything is coordinated right there
and still holding an advantage wants to
give a check again but I want to get my
rook playing at this stage now it's
still holding an advantage and went
there and I guess this is where it's
going to be lost after their next moves
so yeah it's tough to make improvements
for light it's I think it popped up at
one point King DD tuned out saying a for
a good coordination so it's tough to
break down my position there's one
really good piece and as soon as he's
gone I think the evaluation should be
going more in my favor now and then yeah
it is
because well really I'm getting the
bishop and two pawns for the rook I'm
not really sacrificing anything it's
more than that because he's worth more
than upon it's like I'm getting three
pawns in a bishop for a rook this guy's
worth two he's worth one the bishop so
maybe in this endgame there was a better
way that I could have converted it not
sure
like I was saying in the game I would I
would have preferred to hang out to my
e-pawn just so I could have a nice group
of pawns trying to roll down the board
and I get a bit more easily control both
color complexes I subject myself to
potentially being blockaded on the dark
squares when I trade my e pawn for their
F pawn but due to my strong King
position right in the center it was
tough to even do that and because of how
many pawns I'm up at this point it's
okay to even give one back the big
important point to take away from this
position after let's say d4 and what I
play Bishop to e4 is right here let's
see after Bishop takes on takes and rook
takes it's very important that you keep
the rook on board this is a I want to be
able to control both color complexes
that could prove quite difficult if I
exchange a pair of Brooks so I want to
keep this guy around to keep the White
King honest I want to be able to put him
literally in check I want to challenge
him and somewhat so no thanks on the
offer of rook exchange and then I sweep
in and it should just be gone from here
I know I have coordinates and everything
is strung together King is central and
the White King is pushed to the edge and
they eventually just dropped a rook
right around here their next move still
- - ish and after here it's just
completely gone I could have converted
the final stage better by not dropping
my a pond he works so hard one move two
moves three moves and he ends up getting
picked up but I'm able to just give up
some more material as you saw
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video this French
way know our game are you a fan of this
opening slash variation feel free to
leave any feedback in the comment
section below as usual I hope you're
having a good day
and I will catch you soon that's all for
now take care bye
you